can you go back and kind of tell us a
little bit what was the purpose of the
documentary and why did you guys choose
to go to
north korea and china to shoot this and
how did this whole thing happen
um so before we
you know we i take you you guys to the
the later day of march 17th i want to uh
share how i ended up working on that
documentary about
human trafficking in china so it was a
2005
i was working for current tv at the time
and i
got to know about documentary
correspondent it was about following it
was about
north korean defectors family for others
and young little toddler and they
were about to enter the
consulate of consulate in china so
because they were told that if they
cross the gate
they would be safe and they made safely
to china and then they tried to
cross the consulate gate and then they
stopped by the chinese soldiers
and there was a young girl who was
standing confused and
scared while watching her mom and
grandma was wrestling with the
chinese soldiers at the time i had
uh i just had a baby and she was 10
months old whenever i came home
whenever i helped my baby it reminds me
it reminds me of that little toddler
with pigtail
wow and i told my husband we gotta do
something about these people i
heard about north korean defectors a
dangerous journey
uh to escape their country and
their situation in north korea but my
life was busy as well so i kind of
moved on and four years later 2009
i had finally had my own opportunity to
tell their stories
and there were some reports about how
numbers of north korean defectors
growing
still and their conditions especially
for female defectors
are really gotten worse in china
and they were prayed to be human
trafficking like they were sold to
uh farmers wives inaudible sex workers
and sometimes they were deceived when
they crossed and they didn't they don't
even know
what are they are facing when they cross
the border right
so my team and i were we traveled to
south korea and
china to shed light on their conditions
and it was a very important story to us
to tell the world because there are so
many stories out there people don't know
about
we thought this is one of the stories
that people need to pay attention to
their condition no one writes in china
so
that was march 17 was our last day
actually was filming
in china and we next day it was a day
that we were about to head to the u.s
so in the morning very early in the
morning we wanted to have the last
shooting
uh showing the border between china and
north korea so we were at the north
eastern china
where the tuma river crossed between the
countries
and that's we're told that that's the
route that a lot of north koreans take
to escape and march 17
that region is still freezing and cold
winter time
so river was still frozen so we were
walking the
frozen river and there was no sign of a
border whatsoever no wire bars or no
sign
you don't know that if it's the border
if we did we were not without fixer
our fixer was pretty uh connected with
the area
and unaware of the situation he worked
for
nhk bbc on the same matter before us
so we completely trusted him and
when we were on the frozen river maybe a
few about 30 minutes or so
filming the condition that how freezing
it was
and then where the you know this is the
route that a lot of north koreans taking
and one of our producers shouted
soldiers so i looked back
and there were two small soldiers with
their uniform with rifles chasing us
really fast
so we all ran towards chinese soil
as fast as we could one of our producers
male was an avid
brother so he disappeared fast and
um my fixture our picture was running
next to me
he was like you know are you filming
this
and i thought this is crazy but i
flicked my camera and put my own
underarms
and then i was filming as i was running
wow so while you're running you're
filming this entire event
we you never know what kind of version
you're using you wanted to show the
condition right this
is the one that this uh the fear that a
lot of north korea is gonna face
and in my head just don't if you should
don't chew my head
i want to survive right and
when i was almost close to chinese soy i
saw laura ling
my colleague fell in front of me
and i stopped and she said i can't i
can't move my i can't feel my legs
and i i didn't know what to do but i
knew that i couldn't
leave her there by herself she doesn't
speak the language
and then we were a team and
um our fixture was
and suddenly our fixture and me and
laura was surrounded by these two
soldiers
and we heard about this north korean
board
border guards that how you can simply
bribe them
even defectors they can pay them to
cross the border
or sometimes if you're journalists you
can give them some cigarettes to make a
small talk
so our fixer was telling me the money
money so
just give them pride and money to escape
that situation so i pulled out or
whatever in my pocket and i gave it to
them
and they did not want to take it wow so
i knew something was going wrong
and when my fixture was not able to fix
the situation he ran as well
maybe he wanted to take one of soldiers
you know to
to from the situation i don't know but i
wanted him to run so that he can let
someone our situation sure
and now you know if you don't mind me
asking how many total are you even the
producer that's a very good runner how
many total people were you
yourself laura the fixer the producer
that's four how many more were there
good that was it
oh okay got it yeah
and he i was wrestling with the
um uh the one of serger scrapped laura
and
the other surgeon at me and i saw laura
was uh fainter i didn't know that at the
time she was
hit but she was unconscious on the ice
and um the other soldier was
because i wasn't backing and i know i
was trying to yell and screaming
to get help from chinese soil china he
raised this rifle to to hit me taking
the motion
and i looked at him and he was a
such a smaller he was a small boy maybe
17
or so and he was a hesitant to hit me
at the time so i told him hey let me
walk with you
so i got up you're speaking in his
language when you're saying this to him
you're speaking in korean yes i spoke
korean to him
and we i got up and i crossed the
river with him and that's how
we ended up being detained in north
korea
[Music]
you